こんにちはず不調です皆さん警察権というものをご存じでしょうかそこをちょっと曖昧
な知識しかないんですけども復興事件が起きたりしてハッジを探すときにる約10%が
3人の匂い4大みたいな無駄犯人のところにいくっていうのがよくあるんですけども
今回なと警察犬になるために訓練しているこちらの応援さんに来ていただきました
バーン訓練
ですよろしくお願いします
やっぱのにおいとかすごいですか工夫力というかはいあの
しゅっぱーどテーマは匂いを探しなら得意ません
になることですね
ちょっとい年利がたんですごく実はとより今日はですね弱いどんなに思えるんだろう
っていうのちょっと検証していきたいと思いますで捕まりそうだけど多分
ま
れるとまずい警部二世にこのまま使ってみようと思います今日広い公園に来てるんで
ここのどこかに僕
バンクに僕見つけられてみたいと思います理科室に行ってみましょう
なんか僕の臭いのあるほど待ってもリールカーロス靴下ああっ入れます
[音楽]
前にをいないはずなんだけど
思いますご覧くださいこの方への広さこのレベルの広さで僕ような隠れるんで
the 僕はもうちょっと考えれば本当にそれゼッケン7使われどうか試してみますで
は宜しくお願いします
これを使われてみるがよい
都市をどうしようどうしようどうしようどうしはもう全然見えなくなりましたね
なかなか難しいところに隠れてやら高校はどうだ
こんなところでこれ前から掛けるだけ
もうなんかすごいところに来ましたけど果たして捕まるのでしょうか
[音楽]
風強いからなんか匂いが散漫して大丈夫だと思うんですけど
なんかきてるきてる俺まさかん
[拍手]
ウソ出ちゃう
ウソでしょ
てってれー交えてすごくくらいすごい
空けられます8バエコーナー
よくできましたーアゴいねこれは納得いってねもう一軒だけロスですかこんなだって
風めっちゃいるのに匂いという追われるの怖いですけどちょっと一応 ok いらして
ください溶け合うわけないからな
いきます
これなことを見てないんですよ
そんなことを見てないよね見てなくてバレるのが凄いんだな
これなら難しいだろう
国光ですねー
高校にかけましょう5結構むずいと思うよねもうまた断崖絶壁そして滑り台を抜けて本
に来たのでなかなか難しいと思いますただして見つけられるの母んねーっ
ます
やっぱり2
ていた
やばい
はいというわけで今の2回いって分かったと思いますがマジで匂いだけで僕の場所が
特定されてしまいます
第が私はまだわけではありません良いで負けるということは僕が良いを消してしまえば
良いそうすればこのワンちゃんはひょっとしたら僕のことを見つけられないのではない
勝ちだけで今日の動画まあ世の中ってニューヨーク州小川スプレーとか消臭さいニオイ
責めなくては筑波ないと思うんで理解しそれで戦ってみようと思いますではにおい消し
ていきま斎藤佑樹で何皿いいけども招集できる系のものを準備しました
5まず小川腕だけでボブの匂いをなくしてみようと思います
いやもうここだけすればさすがに秒5入学なっていると思うんで早速これで捕まること
を伝えていきたいと思いますがよろしくお願います次はそうするする良いを隠しました
1番勝負だ
どこに隠れ8日大阿蘇合同がなぁあ
[音楽]
よしここでどうでしょうか
じゃあここで待機します
[音楽]
布の多くまで3 d 浸透よ3 d 新都大丈夫者と無許可血が付いから俺の匂いが
流れるんだろうなぁ
[音楽]
アーサーのルートヤバイぞそれは俺が大大 now 前は
ああれまあかなり一度によってなぁでも
[音楽]
やばいやばいやばいやばいぱれぞれぞれ生まれる場で作っ
無償でぞ
そっかーんあなたすごいねやサウナタブ精進するよとバレますねこれちょっと次のいっ
て打ちましょうあいったわけ消臭スプレーだけど飛び使えることがわかったのでもう
ちょっとは欧州力を上げたいと思います
これはいうやるか
うはそれね駄文僕の臭いはほぼほぼれることはないでしょ敗2分けでご覧くださいこれ
ちょっと僕もこれで使わなきゃいけないんで徹底して匂いを聞かせていただきました俺
の体からが俺の匂いはしていないはずでそれを見つけられが
猫はを上の方に行きましょうね
[音楽]
施工購入しますこうコーナーの多分張らないような気がしますかがってこいやー
ん
2日に難しいようですねだって言い難いんだもん今はどこら辺をぶらついているのかな
あったって恋来は言えばれないっ
持っていません
[音楽]
んじゃないん
馬うーんそうでしょ
[音楽]
me
dea
me あった
はいというわけでちょっとあらゆる手段を使って入力してみたんですけども全部
3つ買ってしまいました目で見ないんです
ですよねずっと下向いて探すルミカって本当に恐れ入りました